luno the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys and welcome back to the
lehigh pen show as usual it is powered by the vc
firm icon plus capital and it is sponsored
by block five so right now with block five
you can get up to i think it's around nine and
a half percent interest on your stable coins
um so pretty great i actually do use them i
really enjoy using them and um if you want
to sign up there's a link in the description and
in the comment section so today we have a really
exciting guest we're going to talk about a really
broad range of topics so it is the macro investor
libertarian youtube host trad fight expert and
all-round extremely knowledgeable individual it is
george gammon george welcome to the show thank
you for having me yeah there's a quite a list of
qualifications but one thing i'm not good at is
social media so hopefully i got that tweet right
yeah no worries no worries we'll see how that goes
but yeah it's good to have you we were chatting
earlier and i was saying that i've been following
a lot of your content your youtube content but
in particular with everything that's going on
in the world right now you have some very um
insightful views when it comes to the lockdowns
and the increased uh government intervention that
we've seen so i want to talk about everything
so i'm really excited to have you but i would
really just like to pass it to you actually and
ask you what would you say right now is the most
important topic to talk about i know that there's
inflation and we've spoken you've spoken a lot
about that on your youtube but what for you right
now is the most concerning thing well it doesn't
matter how much bitcoin you have gold silver real
estate if you ain't got freedom you got nothing
absolutely that sums it up if you're locked
up in a cage it doesn't matter what your
portfolio looks like it doesn't matter
how many dollars you have in the bank
and what people need to realize is it's not just
about freedom i think that's priority number one
but it's also about understanding what wealth
is and wealth has nothing to do with your bank
account uh wealth has to do with how many goods
and services you have access to and i always use
myself as a good example my portfolio today
has a bigger number on it than it did in 2019
but am i richer or am i poorer well obviously when
we look at the standpoint of freedom i'm much much
much poorer but even if you look at it from a
standpoint of how many goods and services i have
access to i'm also poor last time i went to whole
foods 20 of the shelves are barren so that means
i can't buy that stuff it's almost impossible to
get a reservation at a restaurant as an example
it's uh i mean you go down the laundry list of
items that are no longer available and again it
doesn't matter if your portfolio is done well you
are poorer today than you were in 2019 and people
really need to understand that they need to open
their eyes i always use the example of a deserted
island right if you're there with a chest full
of a billion dollars or a billion dollars worth
of gold or you've got your billion dollars with a
bitcoin are you rich or are you poor you're poor
because there's no stuff and this is what people
need to realize and you know there's this massive
push towards authoritarianism but there's also a
massive push to try to convince people that they
don't need to produce that they can just sit there
and float through life and they can speculate they
can gamble or now you know we're looking at what's
coming out with best buy nordstroms and gaap
uh now we're incentivizing say or telling
people that they not only have to go to work
but they can just steal whatever they want because
they're not going to prosecute anyone that steals
a dollar amount under a thousand dollars so it's
this whole just bizarre uh push that we have
in the united states and in the western world uh
and for as far as freedom globally uh that i think
takes us to a very very dark place and this is
the road to serfdom uh if people don't see that
they're just not paying attention to history
you know what really concerns me it's the lack
of outrage that we've seen so in austria vaccines
are now compulsory so we don't know whether that
means you go to prison or whether you get a fine
or whatever that means if you know the government
takes if you don't allow the government to have
full say over what happens to your body so why
you know if it's so obvious for you and i but why
do other people not see it because all they do is
pay attention to bumper stickers on cnbc or excuse
me cnn and msnbc these bumper sticker slogans what
they're trying to do is they're trying to take
complex topics and they're trying to understand
them with very very basic slogans that you can
fit onto a bumper sticker and unfortunately
the cerveza sickness if you want to
call it that it doesn't work that way
it's it's like the weather it's like the economy
that it's incredibly complex and to sit there
and just say that uh a medicine as an example is
just quote unquote good or it's quote unquote safe
what does that even mean you've got to define
those terms and i think you know i was listening
to some people in the mainstream media and their
arguments uh that they have because i'm you know
i always constantly ask myself maybe i'm missing
something right and it and if it's the bottom
line is they're not doing any research because you
have these slogans that are just repeated over and
over and over and over again in the mainstream
media so people that don't have the time to do
the research they just think they're obviously
true uh when in reality they have nothing to do
with re uh with what is accurate and they're just
completely fiction they've been made up to push
a narrative that's really the bottom line uh as
an example you know they're saying that uh these
call them medicines uh reduce the rates of
transmission and that's just not true if you
look at the uh the viral load it's the exact same
with uh regardless of what your medicine status is
that now you could say well it's a reduced
chance of getting this race sickness in
the first place uh well that's fine but then
you have to ask yourself if someone does get
the cerveza sickness and they've chosen to take
the medicine what are the chances that they get
symptoms it's a lot lower that's the one that's
the defined benefit of the medicines okay so if
you have that same viral load if you're out
there walking around going to work you're at
the going to the the house party you're going to
thanksgiving dinner you're doing all these things
going out to the mall you don't even know you're
sick you don't even know that your viral load
is so high that you're most likely transmitting
that to other people whereas if you have chosen
not to get the medicine then you're going to know
you're sick and you're going to have symptoms so
this is the nuance that is required in these
types of debates that are completely void uh in
the mainstream media and unfortunately um you know
people just go along with it and i i don't that's
the part that i can't understand why i think we
need to have some level of skepticism especially
when these institutions and politicians have been
lying to the people from the get-go i mean how
many times does someone need to lie to you until
you become skeptical of what they're saying right
i mean when fauci comes out says oh mass don't
work and two weeks later oh masks work and then
biden says in in december 2020 we'll never have
mandates in the united states and six months later
you got mandates in the united states he says oh
we're never going to need a boosters and he says
oh well actually you need boosters and they
say well why why did you lie well we had to
because if we wouldn't have lied then people would
have done what we wanted them to do and they just
come out and admit it so i don't understand how
someone as an example the five-year-old child
can listen to an individual or an entity that
has lied to them over and over and over and
over and over again and now tells you that a
specific medicine that we really don't know
the long-term consequences is quote unquote safe
for your five-year-old how do they believe them
at this point in time it's just it's absolutely
staggering to me but the good news is you're
seeing a lot of people really push back i just
did a story about uh 600 employees at google
that signed a manifesto to the management
where they're pushing back against the mandates
and they're articulating their position extremely
extremely well and i think that's another way that
you can determine who's kind of right or who's
wrong on this topic is listen to the people who
are opposed to the mandates and listen how well
thought out their argument is and how much data
they have and how many studies and facts they have
and then listen to the people in the mainstream
media that are just telling you just to blindly uh
take this you know foreign substance and inject it
into your body regardless of whether or not you
have natural immunity or regardless of whether
or not you're uh you're pregnant or regardless
of whether or not you're you're five years old
you know listen to their arguments and you'll
notice how shallow they are they're completely
void of facts or data at pretty much every level
and i think that's another way that you can
easily tell uh you know who you should believe
who you shouldn't believe or at the very least
be skeptical of those individuals and entities
that are just um you know espousing these bumper
sticker slogans with nothing to back them up so
the question then really is why why are they lying
why are they mandating these things if you
know you brought up a really interesting point
if you're if you've had the medicine i like
the use of that word smart um if you've had
the medicine um and um you're going about your
day you can still pass it on but obviously you'd
have lower symptoms and so that could be dangerous
but if you haven't had the medicine then you would
feel sick and you stay at home and you wouldn't
pass it on that's really interesting that's a
great piece of nuance there that we're not talking
about so why why is that happening now you have to
also have had the medicine to enter the united
states and the land of the free not so free so
it's it's it's getting worse like this freedom is
um they're really clamping down on it um boosters
just to say they also spoke about in the uk um
people over 65 if they haven't had the booster
then maybe they may not be able to um take
part in in certain parts of society so that
would be my parents unfortunately um so why it's
absurd because they're trying to condition you
see it goes back to the psychological
study that i referenced a lot in my videos
it's called the foot through the front door
theory and what happened these psychologists
i believe they were in california they went
into this neighborhood and they asked the first
group of people if they would put a small sign
in their front yard i think it's something to
the effect of please slow down and the the group
of those individuals who said yes they kind of put
them in a bucket then they next went to another
group and they asked them to sign a petition
so something a little different there was
an ask there but it was slightly different
uh and then they went to a third group and they
didn't ask them to do anything for the first round
okay then they went back to those three groups and
they said okay now what we'd like you to do is put
this giant sign in your front yard saying pretty
much the same thing so the group that they didn't
ask anything of to begin with less than 20 percent
said yes to the big sign the group that did
that had something they agreed uh to do but
was slightly different that was the petition uh
their rate of acceptance for the big sign was
about 55 percent with the group that agreed to
the small sign over 75 percent of those people
agreed to a big sign see so what this tells us
is that just the way we're hardwired as human
beings when you get us to agree to something small
the probability of us agreeing to something bigger
and bigger and bigger in the future uh increases
so you start off with well we'd like you to wear
these masks okay we'll do that oh actually you
know what we'd like you to lock yourself in
a cage and oh yeah thanks for doing that but
actually we want you to shut down your your
small business and oh actually you know now
we need you to wear five masks and oh yeah
thanks for doing that but now we need you to
inject this foreign substance into your body and
oh yeah you did that but now we need you to do
it to your kids as well and you see my point
there is that this is a way to condition you
to get you to agree to things that you never
ever would have agreed on just or agreed to do
back in 2019 but the problem here and especially
for the do-gooders who want to stick up for this
mandate the people who truly do believe that it's
still about health the problem there is that once
the cerveza sickness is in the rearview mirror
assuming we get to that point the power and the
control that you give to the government is
not going to go away they're not going to
give it back to you that freedom and liberty
they take away you're not getting it back you
see but the pr but even if this conditioning
process was unintentional it still sets society
up to be controlled to a greater degree than
they were before and that is the the real
problem here when you're doing a thorough
cost benefit analysis as far as these these
mandates these policies the lockdowns uh the mask
mandates the the medicine mandates you know just
list whatever policy you want to throw out there
when you're doing a thorough cost benefit analysis
you not only have to determine what the dangers
of the cerveza sickness are you also have to
determine what the benefits of the the medicine is
and people who do a cost benefit very few do but
the people who do a cost-benefit analysis at least
they do those things but what they completely omit
which is the most important thing is how dangerous
is the government that you are seeding that power
and control to how dangerous are they how big
is that government and what is the probability
that they use that power and authority against you
and your kids and your grandkids decades into the
future you know one of the uh the supreme court
decisions that i reference a lot in my videos
and people who are pro-mandate they always
bring this up as though it somehow backs their
position and this was the the supreme court case
or decision in 1905 jacobson versus massachusetts
and this was regarding the smallpox medicine we'll
call it and this was not to force people to get it
it was just they had a simple fine if they didn't
it was five dollars the equivalent about 150 today
and so this jacobson fellow said no i'm not going
to do that so it went to the supreme court the
supreme court sided with massachusetts
so he had to pay the five dollar fine
and so people reference that say well there you
go there you go see the supreme court already
decided on this in 1905 so the government should
have the power to do anything they want today
because back in 1905 they made that decision you
see but what they're not or what they're omitting
from the argument most likely intentionally or
maybe they're just completely ignorant is the
supreme court decision in 1927 and this was buck
versus bell so the reason we got buck versus bell
or the the reason the decision was made is they
directly referenced the 1905 decision so this set
the precedence for what we saw in 1927 buck versus
buck versus bell well you say well what was that
decision that's the decision in the united states
that legalized eugenics okay that most people
don't even know that was part of american history
because we like to sweep it under the rug but 1927
the supreme court said that it was legal to force
sterilization upon people in the name of eugenics
and the precedence they used for that decision
again was 1905. so the cost-benefit analysis today
that we need to do is not just what's happening
today or in the next six weeks or the next six
months but we need to ask ourselves if we give the
government this type of control and power if we
set this precedence today in 2021 what's it gonna
look like in 20 years for our kids and grandkids
that's the question we really need to ask and no
one's doing it i think that's such an important
point because i mean earlier you mentioned did we
not learn anything from history and people often
say we have a great government they care about us
they're very nice what's the problem particularly
with the democrats and and all of that so how
would you put it to somebody you know how would
you put it to someone and you would say what do
you mean you trust your government how can you
trust your government you don't know who could be
in power tomorrow how can you yeah it's easy all
you have to do is look at the size of government
uh because there's a direct correlation with the
size of government and how psychotic the people
that apply for those positions are going to be
essentially or the level to which they are
a sociopath because you think about it the
larger the government is the more control it has
over the economy and society and the individuals
in that society so if you're someone who
is a sociopath well then you're you have a
strong desire and an insatiable lust to have power
over over other human beings and therefore you're
going to do your best to become a politician and
you're going to do your best to work your way uh
you know to steal to lie to do anything that you
need to do which is basically how politicians win
uh you're not gonna have any moral backbone
you're not gonna have any ethical north star
whatsoever you're going to crush whoever you need
to crush you're gonna say whatever you need to say
to get to the top because you have that insatiable
lust to control other people see you're psychotic
right now if we had a small government like we did
let's say back in the early 1800s well then you
would have people like george washington where
you literally had to twist their arm for years
to get them just to be the president of the united
states and they kept saying no no i don't want to
do that i just want to go up to martha's vineyard
i want to be a farmer now i'd want to do that
why because that attracted the right people
when government is small and government doesn't
control the people or maybe better said when the
government is afraid of the people yeah instead
of the people being afraid of the government
that's when it attracts the people that you want
to have as politicians right when the when the
people are afraid of the government when it has
that much power and control then you're gonna get
people in there that are these uh future dictators
or have the the propensity to be a dictator and
even if you say oh george that's crazy talk oh
that's never gonna happen in the united states oh
really oh really well look what what is happening
right now in australia where they're literally
sending people to quarantine camps that not just
have the survey sickness but anyone that was in
proximity of those people and not in the entire
country to be fair but even if that's happening
in small territories what's the next step
you don't think that we're on a slippery slope
right there and see the people will always push
back and they'll say oh george well that reference
to the 1930s in germany that's just using uh you
know hyperbole that's just exaggerating that's
just going over the top that's ridiculous
give me your proof why see that's what those
people can't do they can't give you a reason why
why is australia not going to be germany in 5 or
10 years why is the probability absolutely zero
no it's not and i would argue they're
getting closer and closer and closer to that
all in the name of safety and freedom or safety
and security which by the way was the exact same
argument that they used in the 1930s in germany
you know you know people forget that that
those germans that went along with that campaign
those the ordinary you know average john jane
these people were not demons these people were
not immoral what they were but they were persuaded
because we have this flaw as in our hard wiring
where we are easily persuaded to do something
that that in another circumstance
would seem absolutely crazy
and we need to realize our vulnerability
to that and australia is a perfect example
see so my point there is if you go back to 2019 i
would have told you that they'd be sending people
to essentially prison camps in uh us in australia
in a year and a half you would have told me that
i was out of my mind that i was i'd probably
believe the probability of that was literally
zero literally zero so if we're seeing that
today well then why can we not see something
more extreme in five years and why could we not
see something that looks like germany in 10 years
are the australians somehow immune to it are
they immune to those same forces of persuasion
that took over the german public i don't think
so so how far um do you think this is going to go
well i think there's some reason to be
optimistic there uh because i i you know i
go around the country i do a lot of uh
public speaking and i just did an rv tour
throughout texas and uh in tucson arizona and
i'm meeting people face to face and i believe
that the people out there that value the
sovereignty of the individual that are that
see this push towards ether authoritarianism
and are extremely concerned and they want
nothing to do with it because they have studied
history i believe that they're the silent majority
and that makes me uh not only optimistic but that
puts a lot of wind in my sails whenever i'm going
whenever i'm having a bad day or whenever
i'm you know trying to find the motivation
to do six or seven uh videos on the
topic uh you know monday through friday
on the rebel capitalist channel that uh and
you know i'm a big fan of the second amendment
yep uh which is you know people's rights to
own firearms but i'm an even bigger fan of the
ability to have like-minded people come together
and practice civil disobedience i think that's
has even more power and uh the example i use
is phoenix that's where i am right now a town
of about four million people so if you would have
gone back to the the lockdowns let's say in march
april of 2020 and you would have had three or 400
guys that have gone out to the streets uh that
would have posed the mandates with guns let's say
they would have been wiped out i mean instantly by
the military or the police who knows what would
have happened but that would not have gone well
but if all four million people would have
just said no we're not going along with your
lockdown i'm going to go walk my dog i'm going to
go to the gym i'm going to go to my college i'm
going to go to the restaurant the small business
owners would have done the exact same thing
and as a group they would have practiced civil
disobedience what could the government have done
what would the police have done what would the
military nothing absolutely nothing and another
great example is the berlin wall yeah you know
how did the berlin wall come down was it that east
germans just went out there with a bunch of guns
no no it's just that you had a group go out there
that were that was fed up that they got to the
point a tipping point where they valued freedom
and the freedom of their kids and grandkids
far more than they valued their own safety
they went out to the wall and
then other people saw them do it
that silent majority and all of a sudden the
silent majority wasn't silent anymore and those
people went out to the wall pretty soon you've
got these guards out there with the guns
but they're surrounded by thousands and thousands
and thousands of people and they know darn well
that if they use one of those guns their
life expectancy is about three minutes
see so what do they do they drop their guns and
the people tore down the wall and that was the end
of communism see it was from the silent majority
coming together and practicing civil disobedience
and i think that that's uh something they did back
then very effective i think that's something that
we can do today that we just as effective so
this kind of makes me want to go down a little
tangent um we don't have to go too far down
it i would be interested to hear your opinion
um so civil disobedience um and you mentioned um
in phoenix the picture that you kind of painted to
me was you know strong men going out there leading
the way i don't really think of it as like as
women i think of it as strong men yeah i use the
example of men going out there with the guns yes
uh because i just wanted to point out that even
if you got these strong guys out there that are
you know six feet tall 250 pounds if they got it
doesn't matter they're gonna get wiped out uh the
greater power uh is when women men everyone stands
together uh as a force and practices the civil
the civil disobedience yeah but still on that
point of men going out there with the guns and
so on and so on i do believe that it would be
men are technically bigger than women men are
technically stronger than women physically and
i do sort of feel that it would be men strong
men that would lead the way and fight communism
like i'm sure if we looked at the vernon wall
the ratio of men to women who actually were
able to pull that thing down would be men
so a lot of people often say that there's a
war on men right now like a war and masculinity
um there's like a lack of empowerment you know the
idea of toxic masculinity we we're not allowed to
see men be strong and they're kind of trying to
pull men down to the level maybe physically where
women are at i wonder if you had any thoughts on
that and whether yeah i don't want anyone to eat
meat they just want you to eat more and more soy
products which will reduce the testosterone levels
of uh the average male by even more than it's been
reduced i mean the average testosterone level of a
male in the united states i don't know the exact
figures but it's dramatically lower today than
it was let's say in the 1950s or the 1960s so
if you're a dude and you have low testosterone
that that does not bode well for your ability
to stand up and go out to the berlin wall
i i can tell you not only your ability
but your willingness to do that
uh you know that usually comes from a significant
amount of testosterone so i think that could be
and i don't have any facts to back this up
but that could be why when you see the world
economic forum's plan uh for 2030 it's that you
you'll eat no meat and you'll just continue to
eat these soy products and there's no protein
there you know we don't want you increasing your
levels of testosterone we don't want you going to
the gym because we want all the males out there
just to basically be neutered uh in the corner
and just shut up so we can control society good
to know that you share the same opinion um so you
speak about the silent majority how hard is it for
you to go out and say these things i personally
find it very difficult um i still try to i find it
quite depressing at the same time so i don't like
to have my twitter feed just full of it um but
you have to be brave and you have to be willing to
be fired you have to be willing to be ostracized
you have to be willing to have your family not
speak to you um so how do you go about doing that
and what advice would you have for other people
who feel the same way but are afraid to speak up
well let me uh yeah so first and foremost with me
i i feel a great sense of responsibility because i
do realize that i'm in a very unique position
i retired in 2012 at the ripe old age of 38
so i don't need youtube i don't need a job i don't
need money i don't need any of that stuff i've got
plenty of it right so i've got that financial
freedom uh not only that i don't have a family
uh well i've got a family i shouldn't say that
but i don't have a wife uh so i don't and not
only that but from a standpoint of what i do uh i
don't have any investors i don't have anyone that
uh is relying upon me to a significant degree
so i can be as irresponsible as i want to be
and i've got the financial wherewithal to weather
any type of storm so i realize that this movement
if you want to call it that it needs people who
are willing to go out there and be a lightning rod
and that don't have to back down to the vocal
minority let's say uh the mob on social media
on twitter or wherever they they sprout up and
uh again i realize that i'm in a unique position
there so that just gives me a further sense of
responsibility to make sure that i am standing up
and fighting for the principles that this country
was built on a really western civilization was
built on and really standing up for freedom
liberty and free market capitalism now as far
as the average individual i understand they are
not in my position by any stretch so they have to
be very cognizant about what they say i think some
of the things that you can do to move the needle
is just really with your friends family members
co-workers i would start talking to them about
bitcoin i think one of the you know people always
like to talk about the price direction of bitcoin
where it's going i think that's the least
interesting thing about it uh i think that's
maybe a way to sync the hook because a lot of your
uh i call them friend and family member fred's
you know just your typical uh you know cnn
viewer there that you know on your facebook feed
or whatever uh they they might not get interested
in bitcoin if you start talking to them about the
principles of hayek or or eases or something like
that but if you start talking oh you know did you
see bitcoin went up by 20 or you know 100 in the
last six months oh really wow oh man i my pension
fund might be you know might not be there in the
future what is this bitcoin thing i've heard about
it let me let me know more or i want to understand
more so then you introduce them to bitcoin but
then what hopefully they'll do is they'll under
start to understand the principles of sound money
i think that's what makes bitcoin very interesting
it's it's the philosophy behind it and then once
they are introduced to the concept of sound
money then they'll most likely get into austrian
economics and then from there it's going to lead
them straight into the value of the individual
sovereignty freedom and liberty and so i think
that's a very indirect way that people can really
affect change in their local community but i
would argue the same thing about gold you know
maybe that's a conversation that you can have with
some of your buddies at the bar or some of your
you know girlfriends when you guys are out is
just talking about precious metals uh because i
think that's another way that they'll go down
that rabbit hole if you will and come to the
same conclusions because it takes them uh and it
introduces them to the value of those sound money
principles that we were talking about earlier and
then they stumble across the freedom and liberty
movement maybe uh libertarians like ron paul or
tom woods bob murphy et cetera and then lastly uh
that's another thing that i do is maybe just at an
appropriate time uh send them a video of ron paul
and uh i i i love ron paul for on for a lot of
reasons but what's one of the great things about
him is he's very um it's tough to hate ron paul
and even if you're someone that's way on the left
your typical bernie sanders or uh aoc type
or someone that watches cnn constantly
it's it's tough to get mad at ron paul oh i hate
that guy he's he's just uh you know he's a crazy
alt-right uh racist or misogynist or something
like that and so if you send them some videos of
ron paul talking about the values of freedom
and liberty maybe not some of the hot but
excuse me the hot button issues that we've been
talking about on this video but maybe some more
um you know benign topics uh just kind of zooming
out and looking at the society and the principles
and why we should value freedom over
safety and then again let them kind of
digest that information and hopefully they'll
consume more and three or four months later
you'll talk to them and they'll say you know what
i i really appreciate you sending me those videos
and in addition to the ron paul videos i just
recently read the road to serfdom by hayek and
you know i want to talk to you about this i think
that's the best thing that the average person can
do yeah i definitely agree with you um that the
philosophy behind bitcoin for me personally is
the most um exciting thing the the fact that
it does um empower personal responsibility um
individual freedoms and so on so how did you first
come across bitcoin because obviously i know you
come from the traditional financial world so how
did you come across bitcoin well i don't know if
i came from the traditional financial world i've
never taken a finance class in my life i've never
taken an econ class i almost flunked out of high
school uh so i was just but you you focus more on
but you focus more on on the traditional side
of things i mean like you said you retired at
38 right so that was obviously before bitcoin
yeah that was that wasn't by through investing
uh that was oh okay more than i consume well let's
let's point that out i was producing i'm very very
proud of by the way uh i i didn't get that uh i
didn't get um to a point of being able to retire
financially by buying a you know a house that
went up 10 times in price or by myself so you need
to know but you need to understand money but you
need to be able to understand money and understand
finance and how the world works in order to retire
at 38 right no i disagree no tell me because i was
an entrepreneur i i created stuff that people
valued more than the money in their pocket
and so i was very i i contributed quite heavily
to what i would argue is the wealth of our society
because i was producing goods and services i
was producing far more uh than i consumed and
when i retired i didn't know what the fed
was i didn't know what the yield curve was
i didn't know really uh anything i didn't know
how dollars were created i mean i was completely
oblivious to finance but i knew how to
make money i was a very good entrepreneur
and i think uh ironically enough what the
attributes that make a good entrepreneur are
pretty much the antithesis of what makes
a good investor they're polar opposites
so when i got into the world of investing in
2012 because i needed to invest my own money
or i wanted to i really had to kind of retrain
my brain uh to to think in a much much much
different way but to answer your your your basic
question there when was i introduced to bitcoin um
boys probably in i'd say 2014 maybe 15 right
around that time i was spending a lot of time
in south america so that's when i first started
looking into it and that's what i did is i looked
at the principles behind it and that's what always
fascinated me the most is how we could possibly
have sound money and what that would do to the
overall economy if we had a money that allowed
free market capitalism to produce deflation
naturally i think what just blew my mind was
the fact that you said that you before bitcoin
you retired before you even knew how money worked
i like did not realize that in the slightest from
your videos and from everything um so that takes
me on another rabbit hole in terms of financial
literacy because i'm always banging on about how
important that is um but i guess it's not just
the lack of financial literacy which we need to
improve on but it's also just that entrepreneurial
mindset um and how to build so how did you learn
how to build then and create something or be an
entrepreneur is that something which came natural
yeah yeah it did uh if i for whatever reason um
you know i never set out to be an entrepreneur
i wasn't one of those kids that
said oh i'm gonna be an entrepreneur
i played sports uh i played ice hockey when i
was a kid i played football i played basketball
uh i played golf play and pretty much every sport
that you could possibly play so i was very very
competitive um but i i never thought well i'm
just gonna have my own business i was never
one of those people like a gary vaynerchuk
or something like that mm-hmm um it's just
when i you know got uh what was i maybe 26 27 or
something like that i started a t-shirt business
uh just simply because the fact that all my
buddies were borrowing my t-shirts and so i'm
like well if they like my t-shirts maybe i should
just make some and sell them maybe i could make a
little bit of money and this was right around the
you know the time that the dot-com this would have
been like 98 or something like that and so i'm
like well maybe i can start this website thing
so i started to do that that business went south
you know i lost a ton of money with that of course
but that was the uh that was kind of my entry
point and from there i did some other jobs and
worked for other people and i did some consulting
but then i kept going back to starting my own
business and uh that's what kind of just always
felt natural uh to me and that's what really fit
my skill set uh you know for better or worse i
am the worst employee you could ever have uh you
know i i'm for better yeah i i obviously i'm not
a big fan of authority and i i'm very independent
and i can be slightly argumentative if i feel
he's a great trait if i feel so you're wrong
uh but i am good at uh things like problem
solving uh i'm very good at managing people
i like to lead from the front of the pack and
i've always been that way since i was a little kid
and so these attributes that you really need as an
entrepreneur i think i had those in spades is this
something that i was very fortunate to be brought
up that way or kind of be hardwired that way
genetically and so i always kind of fell
back on that and i i was very uh i was very
good at it um now there are a lot of things that
helped me along the way of course uh with mentors
and one of the things that really helped me the
most was reading um beat the dealer by ed thorpe
and it's a book that i have up on my my bookcase
back here but that's uh i was introduced to that
book way back in probably 2000 or 2001 in 2002 and
i read the market wizards books uh and i noticed
that when i was reading the original the one with
jim rogers uh a lot of the guys had their start in
blackjack and i'm like well that's weird why why
and so you go into then you start to understand
how important probabilities are when you're a
trader or when even if you're a long-term investor
and then i said okay if i want to be better at
money if i even want to be better at my business
because again back then i knew nothing about
economics or finance i was just trying to improve
my business yeah or my business ability i said
maybe i should learn this blackjack thing because
it would help train my brain to think in terms of
probabilities so i started counting cards and i
would go up to the local indian casino i remember
i was in san francisco in marin county and i'd go
to the local uh indian casino and on the weekends
and i would i would literally be there eight hours
uh straight counting cards and uh playing
blackjack and uh i would make very very small
bets so i'd never get kicked out or anything
and but the whole purpose was just to get my
brain to think in those terms and then uh
i did that for probably six months or so
and then i started to apply those principles
to the next business that i had and just really
try to make it a numbers game and i won't
go into great detail but i think that's
one of the main reasons why that next business
became so successful and the business after that
is the one where i had really fine-tuned those um
ideas and that skill set along with the skill set
we were talking about earlier with problem
solving and managing people and being very
ambitious that's another one and self-starting but
i was able to combine all those and then in 2007
i started a business that was uh from a
financial standpoint was extremely extremely
successful yeah i think i'm still so fascinated
um by the fact that you just didn't have that
financial literacy and i think your story's
really interesting um i think i love the fact that
it's it is all about having those skill sets
being um you know it's not just about having a
vision but it's about um not being agreeable
being um competitive um slightly aggressive
in in some ways um with your goals um so yeah i
think that's really important i even think it's
important sometimes for women to be aware of those
things um because i don't think those kind of
um traits come naturally um so i often say you
know if women do want to you know be that ceo
or be you know be more successful whatever it
is then you're going to want to adopt those
those masculine traits at times um so i think
that's interesting um but i want to talk a
little bit actually um about inflation um i saw
a couple of videos that that you um had posted
about it and i think what's fascinating me right
now is the video that just surfaced and i think
it came out of the uk actually um and it was sort
of saying that um we didn't economists didn't know
that inflation was going to be like this um
so like how do i know like i'm in my 20s like
how do i know that inflation was going to be
awful um after all the money printing and that by
the time they opened up the economy so how did how
how did they not know did they know are they lying
what's your take i think they're just
uh ignorant you know and what happens
yeah i think so what what i've noticed is
as we're raised as kids we have a significant
degree of common sense uh the bs meter i think
is is very fine-tuned and when people who are
interested in economics or finance when they
go to college and actually study economics the
whole process i think is really meant to replace
the common sense with graphs models charts and
what you would expect from uh the school of
keynesian economics uh and they really need
to kind of brainwash you it's like remember
that scene in zoolander the original one where ben
where uh will ferrell is trying to brainwash him
and all these little candy canes are going by the
screen here you see the cartoon where the dog's
got his eyes like the toothpicks in his eyes and
they're trying to brainwash them i think that's
what you have to do to an individual when they
study economics in college you have to brainwash
them and to a point where they completely forget
common sense and they completely rely on these
economic models that uh might look good in
a textbook but when you actually apply them
into reality they really don't work and so that's
what i think they kind of fall back on because if
those models if those economic models weren't true
you got to take your stereotypical phd economist
and if those models weren't true then that
would mean their entire career has been a farce
their college degree is a farce yeah pretty much
everything they've done in their life now you're
dealing with some extreme cognitive dissonance uh
so i i think that those individuals would rather
try would rather rationalize why their models are
not working as opposed to actually have an honest
discussion with themselves as to the accuracy of
those models so this perpetuates more and more
and more of these uh uh predictions let's say
where uh to the person just using common sense
they come to the conclusion that how could you
not know that uh you've got the supply of stuff
decreasing substantially because
you're locking everyone in a cage
and then what you're doing is you're giving these
people trillions of dollars i use a chart often
in my videos and i'm not sure about
the uk but here in the united states
uh they have a fred chart which kind of breaks
down m2 money supply and this fred chart shows the
dollars the amount of dollars that are in checking
accounts of american households in aggregate total
all right so basically the amount of dollars that
are in checking counts for the average joe and
jane going into 2020 the number was right around
1.2 trillion today it's 3.6 trillion dollars an
increase of 2.4 trillion when your starting point
is 1.2 trillion so how can you expect or how can
you create that many currency units on the balance
sheet of the average american and reduce the
amount of goods and services produced and expect
anything other than consumer price inflation
it kind of reminds me of that cognitive dissonance
and um being unwilling to accept where you've gone
wrong um given if you you know built your whole
life on something sort of reminds me of what we're
talking about when we're speaking about lockdowns
um and why people are so blind to it i think it's
sometimes so hard to accept that everything
that the foundation of society is built on
um is a lie or is inherently slightly corrupt well
that gets very that gets very deep because you've
got someone's world view that believes we should
have more government that's their basic world view
that's their religion and then you've got the
other group that maybe they believe uh that we
should have smaller government but those are kind
of or we should have more power in the private
sector and then the other group believes we should
have more power in the public sector well you you
can't have the public sec or you can't come to the
conclusion that the public sector is lying to you
about mandates if they're lying to you about the
medicine if they're lying to you about anything
you you can't accept that because if you accept
that to be true then it completely collapses the
your entire belief system because if the
government is lying to you about that then what
are they lying to you about in terms of welfare
what are they lying to you about in terms of let's
call it racial or social justice right what are
they what else are they lying to you about and
then you start going down that rabbit hole and you
come to the conclusion that wait a minute i was
wrong we we don't need bigger government we need
smaller government and i think they're just really
avoiding going down that rabbit hole because
they would rather you know ignorance is bliss
they would rather live their life in a state
of ignorance and be able to sleep at night just
telling themselves that their belief system
is uh is correct morally instead of you know
taking the red pill if you will yes i'm gonna
say discovering those uncomfortable truths
yeah i think it really i know it's so cringy and
um stereotypical but the matrix what a great film
um red pill versus blue pill and actually the
the final one that is coming out uh i think in
a few weeks actually so what uh what an iconic
moment for it to be released i think i think
it's interesting on a lot of different levels
remember when when neo took the red pill and he
woke up in that capsule of gel because he was able
to see reality and all of the other human beings
that were there trapped in that reality and they
thought that they were living just a normal life
but they didn't realize that the machines had them
and batteries yeah in this capsule of gel just
keeping them alive and i would look at that in
terms of what's happening right now in australia
and i say this and people may say that's an
extreme but that my point is at a certain
time you have to ask yourself if
being alive is the same thing as
living you see those people in the capsule in
the matrix they were alive they weren't living
and it's just like the people right now in
australia they might be alive but they're
not living the government is stealing years away
from them ironically all in the name of safety
and the greater good yeah i think you speak so
eloquently about it and i really appreciate um you
speaking out about it and coming on the show and
really just going through all of this because it's
it's so um it's awful um for me it's so unethical
um i've been talking a lot about it on um across
my social media stories and just unethical is the
only word that i that i can really come to um i
don't think there's anything okay about it um and
you're right stealing people's time like i feel
that way i feel i'm in my 20s i feel like my time
is literally being stolen um but it's okay i will
um i i i have other ways to live a great life they
have to they they can't just look at lives lost
they have to look at years lost so let's look
at australia again as an example the average
age of someone there that has passed away from the
survey sickness is 82 years old so let's just give
all those 82 year olds the benefit of the doubt
and say they would have lived another five years
which is highly unlikely highly unlikely yes
they did let's say they have zero or they they
have a thousand uh deaths something like that
and you compare that to florida a country of
relatively the same population they have let's
say 50 000 uh deaths there you say well my gosh
australia is doing so much better of a job
well let's just say that they would have had
the same freedom they would have they would
have not have gone down the path of turning
their country into a totalitarian police state
well then they would have had an additional
50 000 deaths let's just use round numbers
okay well what you're doing there is you're
saying that those five years for the 82 year old
you're gonna have another 50 000 of those okay so
how many years does that equate to that's 250
000 years okay so you'd have an additional 250
000 years loss we say george that's absolutely
catastrophic that's horrible we can't have that
okay but look at your alternatives right as thomas
soul teaches us well there are no solutions there
are only trade-offs right so we've got that uh
as our starting point but what do you have to do
to save those 250 000 years by the way from old
people well you have to lock everyone in a cage
you have to steal years away from the young people
so let's just say that there's a population of 25
million and half of those people 12.5 have been in
lockdown for 12.5 million have been in a lockdown
for one year well now what you've done is you've
taken 12.5 million years away from your population
your young population by the way just to
give 250 000 years to your the population
that's over 80 years old you see how does that
make any sense at all it doesn't whatsoever so
if you're truly concerned about saving years
which is basically saving lives then you should
completely abolish all of these lockdowns and
you should take a stance that florida has taken
and texas has taken among many other states
where you let people make their own decisions
yeah i think it's um phenomenal when you put it
like that i'm actually in florida right now um
and loving it and it just blows my mind because
um the uk is potentially looking at going into
another lockdown europe of course have we spoken
about and i think actually what's the creepiest
thing is and i was thinking about this the other
day um everybody's out here and they're smiling
everybody's happy there's no mask there's no
social distance and everyone is just happy and
then i'm thinking about everything that's going on
in europe and i'm like then is that even necessary
like how can we survive and be okay here yet
where i'm from in europe it's getting worse and
the riots are starting the fires are starting you
know when you weigh those things up and really the
science technically should be the same everywhere
the science should be the same everywhere the
medicine is the same the the disease is the same
um and yet totally different responses it just
it's really heartbreaking you know um but that's
because one group of people are actually living
and the other group of people are just alive
exactly um but george i want to thank you so much
i really do appreciate you coming on and going
through all of this with us um do you have any
last words what are you working on right now where
can people follow you and tell us your twitter and
youtube yeah they can just google george gammon
it's just typical uh spelling of george last names
g-a-m-m-o-n um i'm probably probably too many
things will pop up for my own good there we go
twitter all the social media
and all the youtube channels
yeah guys go follow george um and i think we
just need to have more of these conversations
and hopefully we can um i don't like to use this
expression but wake more people up george thank
you so much for coming on thank you everyone
for watching and we'll see you all next week bye